l'édito échos de jacques sapir usines à
l'arrêt paralysie du commerce chute du
trafic aérien et du tourisme alors que
l'épidémie due coronavirus n'a pas
encore atteint son pic
l'inquiétude grandit sur son impact
économique surtout en chine où le virus
fait des ravages
alors dans quelle mesure ce coronavirus
peut-il contaminer le reste de
l'économie mondiale porte-t-il les
germes d'une récession on voit cela tout
de suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir
bienvenue jacques
merci olivier alors jacques faut-il
s'inquiéter des conséquences économiques
de cette épidémie
eh bien oui parce que les différentes
informations que l'on a ne sont pas
effectivement réjouissante alors il faut
savoir que cette épidémie d'une
coronavirus elle va avoir des effets sur
l'économie mondiale et sur l'économie
chinoise en particulier à travers quatre
canaux le premier canal est celui de la
production
et c'est tout à fait normal la chine est
aujourd'hui le premier producteur
mondial et avec la chine il y a toute la
zone asie-pacifique l'accord et le
vietnam le japon
après il ya la question de la demande
évidemment quand on produit beaucoup on
consomme beaucoup de matières premières
et là aussi il risque d'y avoir des
perturbations importantes en particulier
sur les prix des matières premières une
3 un troisième canal qu'il faut aussi
regarder de près c'est la question du
transport aérien et du tourisme
et c'est particulièrement important en
france où on le sait les touristes
chinois qui ne sont pas très nombreux
mais kim et joue un rôle qui est
particulièrement important dans la
balance touristique française enfin le
quatrième canal c'est le canal bancaire
et on va voir aussi que la les
perturbations dans la production que ce
soit en demande où que ce soit en
production directe et bien vont avoir
des conséquences sur l'activité des
banques et des assurances alors avant
d'aller plus loin jacques je vous
propose de voir comment les français que
nous avons rencontré réagissent à ce
risque économique potentielle regarder
écouter tous les pays sont plus ou moins
touchés alors effectivement lâché n'est
plus
plus touchés parce que le virus est né
là bas mais je pense que le problème est
mondial la croissance mondiale et tiré
quand même par la croissance chinois
donc on est tous concernés c'est c'est
l'interdépendance des économies qui est
des gens qui vont plus travaillé qui
s'enrichit de rester en quarantaine
c'est chez eux les entreprises pas
fonctionné j'ai des amis à pékin
également qu'ils sont quand on est chez
eux qu'ils peuvent sortir une fois par
semaine pour faire des courses
non non tout ça c'est dramatique pour
les galeries chinoise on y voit qu'il ya
déjà des chaînes de production qui sont
arrêtés airbus a arrêté une épreuve
consommateurs de produits finis et plus
et puis sort un impact sur nous
évidemment bat déjà par rapport au
tourisme on a beaucoup de chinois qui
viennent nous visiter donc forcément
cela on les verra pas prendre un petit
moment
sap va marquer le pas un petit peu pour
l'hôtellerie et c'est donc moi je pense
que l'économie française va souffrir un
petit peu ça dépendra de son impact
petite récession voire plus selon les
l'impact sur la société sûre on va dire
l'économie générale
vous le voyez déjà maintenant rembourse
ça remonte déjà tout le monde attend que
ça s'arrête et la chine elle va
rédémarrer beaucoup plus fort encore on
est dans une économie où on s'est mis
pieds poings liés avec avec l'économie
chinoise
tant mieux pour les chinois alors votre
réaction jackass convient d'entendre
bien oui on voit très bien que les
personnes interrogées ont évoqué à peu
près tous les problèmes qui se posent de
la production au tourisme et tous sont
conscients que ces événements même s'ils
sont pour l'instant largement cantonnée
en chine et bien auront une application
auront des conséquences sur l'économie
française alors regardons
premier effet dont vous avez parlé les
arrêts de production sont-ils
significatif oui tout à fait et là il
faut bien voir que en fait on est face à
deux problèmes le premier problème
évidemment que ce sont les arrêts de
production c'est l'effet direct parce
qu'il ya aujourd'hui au delà de one plus
de 23 provinces qui sont concernés et
ses effets directs ils touchent
différents secteurs l'électronique
l'automobile l'aéronautique la pharmacie
alors pour l'aéronautique en particulier
on à l'arrêt de la chaîne de production
deux airbus en chine ce qui a un impact
sur les sous-traitants d'airbus
c'est le cas de safran et sur
l'électronique
c'est évidemment l'arrêt ou le quasi
arrêt des usines foxconn et puis après
on a les effets indirects
ce sont les effets sur les
sous-traitants il faut savoir que la
chine produit énormément de pièces pour
d'autres pays
ce qu'on appelle les chaînes de valeur
est aujourd'hui en particulier dans
l'automobile
ça a un effet tout à fait dramatique
l'industrie coréenne est d'ores et déjà
à l'arrêt et il y a des conséquences
extrêmement importantes sur les
industries françaises italiennes et
allemand eon peut-on estimer réellement
cet impact
oui alors on sait que l'épidémie du sras
en 2002 2003 avaient provoqué une chute
de 0,5 point du pig mondiale le sras
était bien plus meurtrier que le quoran
à virus mais ils étaient bien moins
contagieux or aujourd'hui ce qui pose
problème c'est évidemment cette
contagion qui amène le gouvernement
chinois à isoler des régions entières et
a demandé aux gens de rester chez eux
alors ce que l'on estime aujourd'hui
c'est que le corona virus pourrait avoir
un impact au minimum d'un point de pib
dans le premier semestre il y à des
experts qui évoquent une possibilité de
deux points de pib en moins pour le
premier semestre
et du côté de la demande que va-t-il se
passer alors évidemment quand on produit
beaucoup ce qui est le cas la chine
on est un gros consommateur
matières premières et la chute de la
production engendre la chute de la
demande
on le voit sur la question des prix du
pétrole les prix du pétrole ont baissé
de pratiquement 20 % environ deux
semaines et demie trois semaines alors
ça une importance considérable pour les
producteurs en particulier les
producteurs américains
les petites sociétés américaines qui
produisent essentiellement ce qu'on
appelle du pétrole de schiste qui se
retrouvent avec des revenus très
sévèrement contracter ce qu'il dit sur
le pétrole peut s'étendre à différents
autres matières premières qu'il s'agisse
de minerais ou qu'il s'agisse de
matières alimentaires alors jacques vous
nous avez montré l'impact de l'épidémie
sur la production et la demande dit y en
at il d'autres
bien sûr il y en a deux autres olivier
et en particulier sur la question du
transport aérien et du tourisme
alors il faut savoir qu'il y a l'année
dernière il y avait 2 4 millions de
visiteurs chinois sur 89 millions en
france vous voyez ça ne pèse pas très
lourd en nombre seulement comme ses
visiteurs chinois comme ces touristes
chinois ont un très fort pouvoir d'achat
ils consomment ils dépensent plus
exactement 1700 euros par visiteur alors
que la moyenne
elle est plutôt de l'ordre de 13 150 à
14 100 euros eh bien ça va avoir un
effet tout à fait important par exemple
si le nombre de visiteurs était divisé
par quatre ce qui est tout à fait
possible puisque aujourd'hui il n'y a
plus de flux de visiteurs venant de
chine sur la france et bien si le nombre
de visiteurs était / cap dans l'année
cela se traduirait par une perte de 3
milliards d'euros pour le secteur du
tourisme
c'est considérable et s'est
considérablement plus par exemple que ce
qui avait coûté l'année dernière le
mouvement des jeunes pour le mouvement
des chemises jaunes ont parlé de
quelques centaines de millions d'euros 2
à 300 millions d'euros en coût direct
là on est plutôt sur 3 milliards donc on
voit qu'il ya un poids qui est
considérable
l'autre problème c'est évidemment pour
le transport aérien le transport aérien
souffre beaucoup de cette crise
et si vous voulez une l'ensemble du
transport aérien qu'il s'agisse des vols
intérieurs des vols vers la chine des
vols venant de chine vers les terres
bien on voit que ces cours est en train
de s'effondrer
en fait on sait qu'aujourd'hui il y à
70% des vols aériens intérieurs qui ont
été arrêtés 56 % des vols à
l'international et le nombre de
compagnies qui cessent de desservir la
chine temporairement évidemment le temps
que dure cette épidémie ne cesse de
s'accroître donc là aussi il y aura des
conséquences extrêmement importante
alors jacques vous nous avez aussi parlé
en introduction d'un possible effet sur
les banques en quoi les activités
bancaires pourrait-elle être touché par
le corps d'un virus oui effectivement
olivier et il faut savoir que il y aura
en réalité potentiellement 2 et fait
alors le premier effet est il lié à la
chute de la production les entreprises
s'endettent ce qui est tout à fait
normale en particulier pour
l'investissement mais avec cette chute
de la production elles auront de grandes
difficultés à rembourser leur prêt tout
simple on a payé en fait les intérêts ce
qui veut dire que les banques auront
moins de recettes
et puis d'un autre côté il y a des
grandes sociétés qui se sont assurés en
particulier depuis la crise du sras qui
se sont assurés contre le cas d'épidémie
c'est le cas de foxconn c'est le cas
d'airbus
donc cela veut dire que les assurances
qui sont maintenant intimement liés aux
banques seront amenés à devoir débourser
des sommes d'argent important autrement
dit le secteur de la banque et
l'assurance va être coincé entre d'une
partie une baisse de revenus liés à la
chute de la production et d'un autre
côté des dépenses supplémentaires qui
sont liées à l'indemnisation des usines
à l'arrêt mais cette épidémie est ce
qu'elle peut provoquer une récession
mondiale ou une récession en france
alors oui c'est une question que l'on
peut poser il faut tout d'abord préciser
que cela dépendra beaucoup de la durée
de cette épidémie aujourd'hui on ne sait
pas si on va connaître le pays
de l'épidémie d'ici la fin du mois de
février ici après cette épidémie va
décliner relativement rapidement il faut
l'espérer d'ailleurs compte tenu en
particulier des mesures extrêmement
sévère qu'a pris le gouvernement chinois
mais il n'est pas exclu non plus que
cette épidémie dure trois mois quatre
mois cinq mois dans ce cas évidemment
l'impact sur l'économie mondiale sera
très important alors maintenant l'impact
sur l'économie française
il est potentiellement d'autant plus
fort que l'économie française va mal on
sait que au dernier trimestre de 2010 9
le pibe a diminué de 0 1% alors ça
pouvait être simplement un accident mais
si on se retrouve au premier ou au
deuxième trimestre de 2020 avec une
situation internationale qui est
évidemment détériorés par cette épidémie
avec aussi une baisse générale de la
production liée par le manque de deux
pièces de rechange
le manque si vous voulez de
sous-ensembles qui sont produits en
chine
eh bien oui on pourrait avoir une chute
importante de la production alors que la
croissance était estimé à 1,1 1,2 pour
cent à la fin de l'année dernière les
chiffres réels pourraient se situer
plutôt à 0 7%
c'est un mauvais résultat et il faut
ajouter que d'autres économies sont
aussi très vulnérables
l'allemagne bien entendu et l'italie
merci beaucoup jacques pour toutes ces
explications comme toujours très
instructive à très bientôt sur rt france
merci beaucoup olivier